what topics do we have oh first is ftx
what what is going on there you just
proved my point i feel like these days
everywhere i turn everywhere i look
there's ftx i see it more than i see you
it's here it's there it's everywhere
it's sponsoring lunch what is what is
ftx doing
i like how you pick the topics and for
those i don't know as soon as you as
soon as they show the graphic i don't
know what the topics are until we see
this kind of a little rapid fire
ftx i think the bigger story obviously
ftx is uh they've extended a line of
credit to uh voyager to blockfi they've
bought embeds like there's a bunch of
things that they're doing here uh what i
would say is ftx is uh part of the story
but sam bankman freed also is the
founder of alameda uh research he's also
the founder of ftx
well the big question now is uh you
could make an argument that he is the
warren buffett of crypto
in this exact situation and what i mean
by that is go back to 2008 uh and really
warren buffet's been doing this his
entire career uh but 2008 was a great
example where the global financial
crisis occurred he had a lot of cash he
quote was patient and was uh waiting for
some sort of market downturn when others
were uh being uh fearful he was being
greedy and he stepped in um and take
goldman sachs as an example he actually
offered goldman sachs five billion
dollars and it came out i think two
years ago that it's estimated he made
about three billion dollars on that five
billion dollar bet not bad and so when
you start to look at
uh that situation what you can see is
that warren buffett's entire strategy
have a big balance sheet be patient
yeah strike when others are fearful or
whether there's some sort of market
downturn and so the question now is like
is that what sam bankman freed ftx
alameda and kind of his family of
companies is that what they're doing and
it appears that that is exactly it they
have a strong balance sheet they've got
great cash flow they've talked a number
of times
publicly about how when they went to
raise the last round of funding a lot of
vcs were like hey why don't you guys
have more employees you only have 200
employees at ftx like why don't you have
more employees and they're like because
we don't need more employees like we get
the production we need out of the
employee base that we have well now in a
market downturn all of a sudden they
seem poised to strike and so again it
doesn't mean that the bets they're
making now will end up paying off it
doesn't mean that the bets they're
making now
are the right bets to make so there's
still some selection that needs to
happen and we're going to not have the
answers for this for five years or so
but there are a lot of similarities
between strong balance sheet
aggressiveness and a market downturn
and the ability to capitalize when
others are fearful between warren
buffett and sam bakeman free does that
also can you apply that macro view to an
individual investor as well that
framework of course any individual right
i mean there's a lot of take kind of the
market sentiment if you will off of
twitter right now there's a lot of folks
who are saying hey i i dollar cost
average right and whatever asset could
be stocks could be bitcoin could be real
estate uh whatever and by dollar cost
averaging what i essentially do is i
just pick a number and every single week
or month i just go ahead and i buy
now all of a sudden if take bitcoin uh i
was dollar cost averaging over the last
you know five years or two years and the
price of the asset kept going up and up
and up and up and now i turn around and
the price has dropped significantly you
actually may see people say okay i'm
going to accelerate my dollar cost
averaging i'm going to try to pounce
when there's some sort of price drawdown
now again there's always this risk of uh
are you buying a great asset so the
price has dislocated from the underlying
fundamentals
and so therefore you're getting a
discount to the value you're buying or
the risk is are you actually uh just
catching a falling knife if something
was at 69 000 you buy it at 20 and it's
on its way to zero then like that was a
stupid investment and so that's where uh
the evaluation make in room for error
right like margin of safety yes margin
of safety that is the uh that is the
term uh that would be used and uh again
timeless investing principle from warren
buffett charlie munger etc is uh
buying something where even if something
goes wrong there's a margin of safety so
if you think something's worth let's say
a hundred dollars and you buy it at 40
the margin of safety is 60. so if it
loses 50 percent of the the value you
still would be up because you bought it
at 40 now it's worth 50. and so that's
exactly how uh this ends up playing out
is the timeless investing principles
they always play out and say make me
free to think is doing something similar
what's up with the gas tax when i buy
things on sale margin of safety
all right i don't know how that applies
i just think it's cool okay so
president joe biden said that he is
seriously considering a temporary halt
in the federal gas tax as the white
house looks to step to take steps to
lower the cost of the pump ahead of the
july 4th weekend when tens of millions
of americans are expected to hit the
road so is he basically trying to like
ease the burden on americans wanting to
take road trips
i think that uh
it is undeniable that gasoline prices in
america
not in a good situation um and so when
you see that you then have to ask
yourself okay uh what can they do about
it there are long-term solutions like i
don't know uh allow for more american
drilling encourage uh nuclear power uh
so that we can offload some of uh um the
the attention on energy and then we can
use natural gas or oil um and bring that
online they could go and they can
negotiate deals with uh
saudi arabia venezuela et cetera and so
when you start to see all these
different things that they could do over
the long term you guys that doesn't
solve the short-term problem yeah and so
the short-term problem is either one
until people hang in there and just
experience the pain
two is they can try something like this
around taxes so if you drop the tax yeah
sure maybe it'll have a little bit of an
impact but it's not gonna take you know
five dollar a gallon of gas down to
three dollars so what is it what is it
it's probably pennies
in terms yeah but think of it this way i
don't know exactly what the tax is if
you have five dollar gas and let's say
that that tax is uh i don't know 50
cents
right i'm not a mathematician but like
that would be at least trending in the
right direction because you're getting a
10
less gasoline price and so i don't think
it's 50 cents it's smaller than that but
at least it's something that they could
try and then the
last piece of this um is that they could
actually issue
uh some sort of gas card to america
it's kind of the stimulus checks but do
it for gas the white house said that
would be a stretch so they considered it
which is why i bring it up i think it
would be stupid of them to do this
uh because it would basically be a form
of ubi uh you'd be not only giving
people money as you did with the
stimulus checks and we saw that led to
inflation uh but on top of that what
they would be doing is they would then
be telling people hey by the way we're
going to give you this money and you can
only spend it on this one thing
and so at what point do you start to say
well like oh well if we do it for gas we
should do it for food too food's up 12
you know to eat at home and so when you
start to think through
um kind of what they should do yeah in
the short term i don't think there's
very many things that they can do
except for
the tax so to me this is the thing where
they eventually get to uh evaluate all
of their options and they conclude the
only thing we can do that will have an
impact is the gas tax i think people are
saying it's 18 cents
again 18 cents
i mean you know
if you you it's a it's a big difference
when it all adds up right
sure but also i think that people would
rather have three dollar gasoline for
the next 10 years than have five dollar
gasoline and have an 18 cent you know
tax uh removal for what we're gonna do
for july fourth we're just gonna have a
tax holiday for july fourth only and
then what happens in august
you keep paying your taxes
um wait can i can we do a very quick
short bitcoin break you know what's
crazy to me oh bitcoin at 21 500.
um but it's going to change in the next
like 20 seconds don't believe what you
hear it's very volatile uh
it changes a lot okay who's paying you
i don't know
oh my dollar maximalists are paying you
wait hold on spread that fud go ahead
fudge
um what i want to say is that uh
come on sorry i forgot you lost i had a
train of thought oh yeah um so i was
looking at the bitcoin price and i
remember in 2017 when bitcoin hit 20k
and how many people were like
over the moon excited like running
around doing naked laps not you not you
i'm not not you um
and now
when bitcoin's at 20 000 people are
depressed i would love to see your
search history is everything
isn't that crazy of course fear and
greed index fear and greed index you can
hit you can hit a number
uh
in value and everyone's like oh my god
it's amazing you go and hit the same
number on the way down and people are
like this sucks and it's just crazy it's
just it's just market it's psychology
it's market sentiment again timeless
investing principles apply here what's
going on with unemployment
okay
never mind i had a great idea i'll share
later
that wasn't a good idea so you don't
know my narrator it wasn't a good idea
all right unemployment so
uh larry summers
do you know who that is see this is my
problem with these headlines this is my
problem with these kind of it's a bad
thing no really it's a bad thing this is
my problem with these headlines
i don't i don't know who steve goldstein
is i'm sure he's a nice guy yes treasury
secretary larry summers says that there
needs to be a surge enough employment in
order to cool inflation
like do they understand what he said
this is not what he said literally that
is fake news does not want people to
lose their jobs so okay but hold on he
did say there needs to be a lasting
period of higher unemployment to contain
inflation
listen
you guys want examples of the [ __ ]
that goes on in the mainstream media
this is a perfect example there's a
kid's show no this is a perfect example
larry summers who's a former treasury
secretary
said that he believes that we are going
to have to have
five percent unemployment in america
in order to curb inflation what he is
saying is a chain reaction
so we have high inflation out 40-year
high what ends up occurring is the
federal reserve says [ __ ] there's so
much demand it's pulling prices there's
all these issues monetary policy fiscal
policy supply chain geopolitical
challenges all this stuff we have to get
inflation under control we're going to
make the cost of capital more expensive
we're going to raise interest rates
we're going to conduct quantitative
tightening we're going to be a net
seller in the market rather than that
buyer you're going to take away that a
persistent bid in the market when we do
that asset prices are going to come down
and we are going to destroy demand for
goods and services of course if demand
for goods and services ends up actually
getting destroyed
then the revenue of businesses goes down
the revenue of businesses is going to go
down they say [ __ ] we have to also take
our expenses down or we're just going to
lose money if we have to take our
expenses down what do we do one of the
things is layoffs and so there's a
direct line between raising interest
rates conducting quantitative tightening
crashing asset prices market downturn
you get companies who say [ __ ] get your
expenses under control they do layoffs
unemployment rate goes up so he is not
saying he hopes that this happens he's
not saying he wants it to happen he's
saying that it's going to have to happen
in order to curb inflation and literally
in the article it says put a different
way someone's just calling for the
unemployed rules to swell to roughly 16.
so this is his exact quote we need five
years of unemployment above five percent
to contain inflation we need in other
words we need two years of seven point
five percent inflation five years of six
percent inflation or one year of ten
percent unemployment there are numbers
that are remarkably disturbed
discouraging relative to the federal
reserve view
now when you look at that that's what he
said that's direct quote he said
inflation he meant to read unemployment
i don't know why you changed
unemployment as inflation
now go back to the headline
explain to me how you read that quote
and you hear what he said and then you
get this here's why larry summers wants
10 million people to lose their jobs to
be fair it's probably not the reporter
who wrote the headline so let's cut him
some slack what i don't know what uh uh
i think this was market watch yeah that
did this
again i don't care if it's the reporter
the editor the ceo or the janitor it
doesn't matter who created the headline
that is [ __ ]
and the reason is because it creates all
sorts of divisiveness where now people
are like oh larry summers he wants
everyone to suffer the elites versus
everyone else like no this is a
distraction
it's a bad situation right now the
average american family is suffering and
if they continue to create this
divisiveness where it's simply saying
oh the people in charge the people who
are insiders they hate you
it creates divisiveness just say what he
said
or be informed and think for yourself
okay
tick tock has moved its u.s user data to
oracle's cloud platform the decision
addresses concerns from u.s officials
that the social media company's chinese
ties could pose national security risks
but then i read another article that
said that chinese-based or china-based
staff can access the us-based
uh
uh i'm out on the tick tock data saga i
don't i don't know what's going on
data is just like it just like hides
like they just like put it in the cloud
like i don't know look up in the sky
where is it right like
if you think you know how the internet
works
duh and of course they're like oh it's
in oracle's database it's in this
database it's in this database like it
doesn't matter what database if the same
employees have access to the database
that's what i don't understand is
they're acting as if the concern is
somebody is hacking tick tocks data
that's not the concern the concern is
that you have employees in another
country that we may or may not be
friendly with who have access to data
whether you agree or not with it that is
the thing that people are concerned
about and so to say oh we're going to
take the user's
data and the employees access to that
data we're just going to move to a
different database doesn't solve the
problem that the employees still have
access to it
i know i don't know it's just i
and we don't have all the information
here yeah so many of my friends are on
tick tock and i'm like i don't think
they care i'm the only person in america
that's on tick tock but not on tick tock
no you're not so am i so are a lot of
people no no i'm on tick tock but i'm
not on tv he doesn't have an account but
he can look at the no i don't even know
there's videos of me that get posted
every day but the team posts them i
don't go on tick-tock tick-tock oh yeah
yeah we're bawling on tock let me tell
you i'm all the young kids they're like
yo pop what up tick tock and i'm like
what did i post
i don't even know he says that second of
all are you dancing on there no what are
you doing i actually have only seen a
couple of videos and it's me talking you
know we're you know educating the kids
who is what kids are watching him talk
lewis who some of you don't know uh
messaged us one day and he goes [ __ ]
they got me i'm addicted
it's an easy one that's why i'm not
going on they ain't getting me
they're so good it's like you know when
you're a kid you know how your parents
are like don't do drugs like don't
don't smoke weed if you smoke weed one
time you'll be addicted forever yeah and
they try to like like try to like like
instill fear into you
and then you're like really if i do it
one time i'll be addicted for life like
that sounds scary that's how i feel
about tick tock don't watch the video if
you watch one they got you first that's
true
probably
now as a dad let me tell you sophia
don't smoke marijuana
i have to wrestle the tick tock out of
his cold dead what's going on with
warren buffett
someone paid
an anonymous bidder paid a
record-breaking 19 million dollars for a
private steak lunch with investor warren
buffett i love that he wow
the sale was part of the 21st annual
auction for a lunch with buffett
produced in collaboration with ebay and
the glide foundation yeah this is
awesome that he does i mean 19 million
dollars it used to be like three or four
started so the bidding actually started
at 25k on june 12th and ended with 19
million a while yeah and look obviously
what you have is you have either uh
really wealthy asset managers or
investors who are bidding for this or
you have like ceos doing that right it
probably is who ftx
do you think sam bakeman free paid 19
million dollars to hang out with buffalo
let's look at all the things he he did
uh uh would he donate la in 2020 donated
five million dollars uh fell into uh
well i don't know i guess this is
considered uh philanthropy um but also
has the the weird thing but how about
warren buffett commanding 98 if you make
a 19 million donation you could uh sit
sit next to me while i eat my lunch that
i was gonna eat anyways in the chat
how much would you pay to eat a steak
lunch with me versus him
i i would pay you to eat with me because
you don't think i'm cool
[Laughter]
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time